the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
as you all know hbo is in the middle of
hiring new actors for their upcoming
series house of the dragon
lately i have made a few videos about
which characters will be seen in the new
show
this has made me think about some of the
great characters that were left out of
the original show game of thrones
now all although game of thrones is well
known for having a wide variety of
fascinating characters there were still
so many left out of the show in this
video i want to go over some of those
characters that were never brought to
life on the screen
now i would be here for hours if i
attempted to discuss
every single character game of thrones
left out so i'm only going to discuss
some of the ones i like the most
the characters i mention in the video
might not have a major effect on the end
game but i just kind of think they're
awesome
one of the characters i wish they would
have included was strong belwas who is
one of the most beloved characters from
the books
he's easily one of the biggest and
baddest characters that serves under
daenerys targaryen
for those of you that don't know belwas
was a slave bred
and trained for fighting in marine he is
a veteran
who earned a reputation at those
fighting pits that were in marine
he says he has never lost a fight
although he has all these scars all
over his body now the reason why he has
all those scars on his body is because
he allows
each of his opponents to make the first
strike before he annihilates them
he even tells daenerys to count how many
scars he has on his body so she can know
how many men he has slain
in the books he spends most of his days
guarding daenerys and he even saves her
more than once
when hizdar offers daenerys some food
belwas eats it instead
and he later becomes very ill but
because he's such a large man he does
survive
although it does have a major effect on
his strength and weight
now i will say he's not necessarily a
very fascinating character but he's
still one that i would have liked to
have seen nonetheless
the next character on my list is the
famous fool known as patchface
i think he's one of the most interesting
and mysterious characters
in a song of ice and fire we don't know
what his real name is but the reason why
he's referred to as patchface is because
of the tattoos on his face
and head he has these markings on his
face because
this is the fashion in the free city of
atlantis for slaves who serve as jesters
how this character ends up in the
service of stannis baratheon
is kind of interesting he was bought by
stannis father stephen baratheon
who was sent over to the free cities by
the mad king in search of a bride for
his son rhaegar targaryen
he never does find a suitable bride for
rhaegar but when stephon baratheon
discovers patchface
he immediately sends a letter back to
his maester at storm's end
in the letter he wrote we have found the
most splendid fool
he's only a boy yet he's nimble as a
monkey
and extremely witty he juggles and
riddles
and even does magic he could also sing
songs in four different languages
we've bought his freedom and we hope to
bring him back home with us
robert will be delighted with him and
maybe he will even show stannis how to
laugh
unfortunately however he would never see
his sons again
robert and stannis watched as their
father's ship was smashed against the
rocks and swallowed by the waters that
were within sight of storm's end
everyone on their father's ship died
well
everyone except for good old patchface
the days after the ship
sank his lifeless naked body washed up
on the shore
the maester thought he was dead but when
someone grabbed him by the ankles to
drag him off to the burial wagon
the boy coughed out water then set up no
one has ever been able to explain what
happened while he was lost in the sea
the witty clever lad that lord stefan
had written of never made it the storm's
end
the boy they found was someone else
broken in body and mind
hardly capable of speech much less of
wit
yet the markings on the fool's face left
them with no doubt of who he was now
patchface spends most of his days with
stannis's daughter shireen
what's really interesting is melisandre
has seen him in the flames
she mentions this to jon snow when she
says the creature is dangerous
many a times i have glimpsed him in my
flames
sometimes there are skulls about him and
his lips are red with blood
this is another one of those characters
that might be able to see glimpses of
the future
he is known for singing these very
strange songs that seem to reveal some
of the mysteries of a song of ice and
fire
many of the characters within the story
believe that he has lost his mind
but maybe he knows more than we think
another character i wish they would have
included was lady stoneheart
and you most likely know this already if
you have seen some of my other videos
lady stoneheart is the resurrected
version of lady catelyn
she is brought back to life by beric
dondarrion three days after her throat
was slit at the red wedding
now she is on nothing but a mission of
vengeance
she is looking for anyone who she
believes was involved with the red
wedding
in the books she is reintroduced during
a scene when she hangs one of the
members from house frey
later on when she finds brienne podrick
and another character named sir heil she
attempts to hang them as well
as you all know brienne has one of the
valyrian steel swords the lannisters
made from the stark sword ice
lady stoneheart believes brienne is now
on the side of the lannisters
although we all know she is really
looking for catelyn's daughters
in hopes of getting them back home safe
lady stoneheart doesn't believe her
though
so she gave brienne a choice either you
and your friends hang
or you bring me jaime lannister at first
brienne was willing to give her life
before handing her jamie
but at the very last moment right before
she lost consciousness
she did agree to find him and bring him
back to lady stoneheart
and the brotherhood without banners the
books more or less
end shortly after brienne finds jaime
she did convince him to help her save
sansa stark from the hound now what's
really interesting is
brienne convinces jaime to go with her
alone or else she says the hound will
kill sansa
this is one of the storylines i'm
looking forward to reading the most
in the winds of winter i really wish
they would have went in this direction
in the show
i think it's far more interesting than
some of the other things they did with
these characters
but maybe that's just me another
character i wish we would have seen in
game of thrones was victarion greyjoy
the brother of euron and balon greyjoy
victarion is a very large man who is
known for being a fierce warrior in
battle
now you might not know this if you have
only seen the show
but the reason why euron greyjoy was
gone for so long was because he was
exiled
by his brother baelon you see euron not
only seduced victarion's wife
but he also got her with child when
victarion found out what happened
he beat his wife to death victarion
would have even done the same
thing to euron but he did not want to be
known as a kinslayer
that's why baylon sent him away
victarion has never married since
and he has never forgiven euron either
now
as soon as geron wins the king's moon is
where things begin to get really
interesting with the greyjoy brothers
this is when euron demands that
victarion sail across the narrow sea
and offer a proposal of marriage to none
other than the mother of dragons
daenerys targaryen now it did seem like
game of thrones would go in this
direction but that did not last for very
long
however in the books victarion does not
like his brother
he's actually kind of disgusted with
euron and this is when victarion decides
he wants daenerys for himself
so he set sail for marine but he loses
nearly half of his ships along the way
however during this voyage he does find
himself a red priest
named mokaro who was holding onto some
wreckage out at sea
victarion's men want him killed
immediately but victarion thinks that he
might be useful
he also thinks if his brother euron has
his own wizards then why can't he
now what's really interesting about
makaro is he can see the future
in his flames like so many other
characters in the story
he explains to victoria on how he can
use the dragon horn euron sent with him
to find daenerys
for those of you that don't know euron
has a dragonhorn
that he says can bind dragons to as well
he said he found it during his
adventures at sea
there is only one issue with the horn
whoever blows the horn dies
almost immediately makaro reads the
words that are engraved on the horn
he tells victarion they say no mortal
man shall sound me
and live blood for fire fire for blood
who blows the hellhorn matters not the
dragons will come to the horn's master
you must claim the horn with blood so
victarion is on his way to meet daenerys
who as we all know
has dragons now what i want to know is
will he become one of daenerys's allies
or will he try to steal her dragons by
having someone use the horn
if this would have been introduced in
game of thrones it could have went in so
many other directions
that's something i know i would have
liked to have seen like i said before
these characters i mentioned might not
have a major effect on the end game
they may never become as important as a
jon snow or a daenerys targaryen but i
still wish they would have been involved
in the show
i usually like the characters that add
more mystery to the overall story
let me know which ones you wish they
would have added to the show
and feel free to name as many as you
would like i am interested in seeing
what you have to say
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching the video i hope i'll see you
back
here for the next one have a great day
everyone
bye
[Music]
[Music]
um
you